in the bathroom
oh [ __ ] bird offs herself to express her
undying gratitude team for saving her
ass
i was only gone an hour
checked your pulse
she's gone
how'd this happen i don't know
i told you evie was lying in bed like
always
when i went out and i got back to
[ __ ] if i just known i'd
checked her pulse
she's gone don't blame yourself
don't solve anything i should have
sensed
something that it was off stop
couldn't watch you 24 7. she made up her
mind
would have found a way always
got to do something with her
don't want any trouble i'm calling the
badges
can you carry her to the bed as if
that'll change anything
yeah i i need to report an accidental
death
north side jackson street
no no imminent danger
suicide
no today what part of the dead don't you
understand
no she was not pronounced dead by trauma
team
if she'd have had coverage we wouldn't
be talking and
[ __ ] you if you don't want to move your
asses why don't i come down to the
precinct and trash it into bits
now will you come and arrest me you
[ __ ]
fine i don't give a [ __ ] what you write
me up for
they'll be here soon
told me to keep her on ice until
tomorrow can you believe the balls
you know to you she was your best
friend so it's a terrible tragedy but
they must get dozens of calls like this
every day
what are you the [ __ ] pr rep no just
saying
put something on her i'd rather she look
like a person than a body
could you wait outside
close the door v please
i know you smoked
quit it's been years but
right now i need something inside air in
my lungs please v
just one
sorry no can do cheapskate
could get hooked again i don't want that
on me v
just give me a [ __ ] smoke
sorry no ken cheapskate you could get
hooked again
v just give me a f
sorry fresh out [ __ ] trivi i know you're
not
how don't piss me off not now
here
that was her smoke case
wanna hold on to it
no he seemed to like it keep it
kind of glad it's you that has it
actually
[ __ ] evie
i let her down i thought if i gave her
some
space time she'd get back on her feet
stay strong judy don't let this tear you
down
you know what let's just not say
anything for a minute okay
her condition couldn't think about
anything else tech wise she was clean
dalshard was operational uncorrupted
so psychological trauma
had to be that did some more digging in
her virtues
found woodman he kept her
had his way with her the things he did
and once he got bored he pawned her off
[Music]
what did woodman do to her did you see
it
yeah and i really wish i could unsee it
wait so you found other recordings had
another look
at the corrupted ones you know not the
static hard to pick up anything really
at some point i stumbled
on something like an echo of the spat
we'd had
last time we saw each other but i know
she wasn't scrolling
then why was it saved as a virtue
she got no explanation for it maybe
she recalled it later relived it almost
implant could have been on when you know
as a defense mechanism
escaping into the past so as not to live
in the present
i had no idea that guy was such a
monster
saw him as your average trixie sleazebag
it puts on a convincing facade i knew
him
but i never thought him that sick in the
brain
got to be something i can do about it
like what
don't know yet i think i'll call suze
thanks bee sorry but uh i'd rather be
alone now
promise to keep in touch
sure you don't need anything
no but sweet of you to ask
anything comes up holler on the hollow
[Music]
[Music]
will be fulfilled by his deputy mayor
and closest associated
announced plans to run
today
but when we've dried our tears
to ensure his work will continue on
rest in peace my friend ryan's political
opponent
former district attorney jefferson
perales also
offered his condolences look may ryan
and i often do not meet eye to eye on
political matters and
we sometimes treated shark walks but
even after our most
heated debates we all shared a handshake
of mutual respect
today i say farewell to him for the last
time
thank you lucius for everything you've
done for our city
who next we'll assume ryan's mantle will
find out
[Music]
hey uh what's going on